yo as good as luke check me out on
bootleg cav podcast
welcome to the bootleg cab show special
guest
repping dreamville
we got the homie lutz here what's going
on man and we will start this podcast by
explaining to you what a juggalo is
please
so do you know who the insane clown
posse is yes
okay so that the juggalos are their fans
their fans are
typically i feel like i knew that
already but i yeah they get like hatcher
man tattoos and they're typically like
pale and smelly
um
they have like meth problems
mostly uh
they were designated a actual gang
by the fbi
right yeah so you know how like the
crips and the bloods and hell's angels
the juggalos are designated a gang
through the eyes of the federal
government
it's [ __ ] deep yeah you've never been
to a icp show
yeah you get so they shoot two liters of
faego soda into the crowd
and everyone's just items it's pretty
crazy yeah that sounds nuts
well listen man welcome to the to the
show uh appreciate you glad to finally
have you up here i've been bothering an
interscope to have you up here for i
feel like a couple of years now yeah
well you got the album out now yeah
uh you're from charlotte and
i was just talking to stunner for vegas
about just north carolina having a
moment right now
um
and charlotte has had well not charlotte
but north carolina in particular has had
such a uh just a crazy history in
hip-hop because one of my favorite
groups so you got on that little brother
is from the center for vegas had no idea
who the [ __ ] little brother was i tried
to explain it to him i mean it'd be like
that because no i get it like the age
the age difference you know yeah but um
north carolina just in general man it
feels like there's just a dope wave and
energy coming out of the state out of
the carolinas in general what do you
think like special about what's coming
out of your region at the moment um that
everybody don't sound like each other i
think that's i think that's the
beautiful part about it like we don't
have a
distinct sound i feel like uh and i feel
like that's fire because you see how
many
um how many different types of artists
come out of either the city or the state
right so i think that's just fine as
hell yeah because like you know you got
like obviously cole guys like yourself
and then you got the baby who's also a
lyrical monster and then you got stoner
for vegas who's doing like
you know street [ __ ] and so i just think
there's like a dope diverse like
roster of guys that are coming out the
city right now it's all the same [ __ ] uh
really you know what i'm saying like
it's all the same [ __ ] but like
different genres different everybody
talk about it differently
yo you put little brother on the album
which is amazing by the way if you're
watching this don't go stream minstrel
show or the listening because [ __ ] abb
records that being said precisely go
listen to their last album um
but
how big of a deal was like little
brother to you growing up being in in
north carolina um it was it was pretty
big like especially um just the way they
did things and um and the impact that
they had on because how old are you i'm
32. okay so we're we're about the same
age
i'm 34. so you were there so you were
like tap yeah yeah yeah so i mean yeah i
mean they're they they're the i mean i
remember
hearing the listening for the first time
it was like
a moment man um my friend's brother put
me on the listening and i was like damn
this is fire i'm like from north
carolina it's like yeah they go to
central
it's like i was fired
yeah and then obviously ninth wonder
just having a hell of a career as a
producer yeah for sure now as a
professor
uh minstrel show was like which which
which album do you prefer minstrel show
or the listening
uh the listening honestly really yeah
it's close for me yeah i go back and
forth man the minstrel show i remember
like i think the minstrel show cause i i
i would like
they opened up for dilated peoples on
tour when the minstrel show came out i
remember seeing that that that like live
and it like just stuck with me in my
high school years like seeing the
menstrual show like that album being
performed live honestly i got put on
like later
down the road i didn't get it as soon as
it came out right type [ __ ] but um when
i did hear it i was like damn
[ __ ] just tapped in
you know what i'm saying
like
especially in the area where they came
out
and everything else that was going on
music i'm like damn they like stuck to
their guns with their with their [ __ ]
you know fonte is one of the greatest
fonte is that guy yeah fonte sequenced
the album
wow yeah so what talk about your
relationship with fonte cause um pool's
my manager wait rapper big boos wait how
did i not know this i think he might
have told me this
because he's been he's been managing for
a while right
that's crazy
yo he told me that when i saw them last
right after the last album came out pooh
was telling me he was managing you yeah
i totally forgot about that bro
damn that's crazy that's how that works
so rapper big poo is your manager
one of the nicest guys in the just ever
nah who's fire who's a [ __ ] great guy
man literally my brother no pun intended
that's just amazing bro i totally forgot
that he he because i i i had talked to
them um
right after i want to say it was
the end of 2019
it was right before it was like right
after the album dropped
so yeah now he told me that two part two
yeah now he told me he told me that i
totally totally spaced that i'm glad you
brought that up
so yeah so you got i mean you got
fontaine and pooh just in your back
pocket so [ __ ] is lovely nah she was
fired yeah to be honest when um
when they played the album back i really
didn't know what i had at the time so
when they played it back i was like damn
this is crazy this just sounds amazing
yeah you know it's it's crazy how
important like sequencing is very
important because honestly i was just
making music i'm like man
i ain't got [ __ ] here who's gonna put
some [ __ ] together or whatever like i
just didn't know what i didn't know i
didn't realize what i was making like i
you know
i knew the process i knew my process and
what i was going through and how i
wanted to express myself doing it
but i had no idea what direction how i
wanted how i wanted it to be so hearing
it all singles together with you know
the musicians and all that [ __ ] it's
just like damn this [ __ ] is so beautiful
yeah it's crazy because if you think of
like classic albums like if the if you
moved around the songs
they might not hit the way that nah it's
about it's all about when you press play
how that journey let's see that's how i
am as an artist all my
bodies of work i want them to be
listened to from top to bottom yeah you
don't want people to just go listen to
the single you want them to appreciate
it all the way through so you get the
story and you get everything and um it's
an experience i want people listening to
my [ __ ] and being experienced
well whose idea was it to have fonte
help sequence was that your idea his
idea or pooh's idea or it was pooh's
idea
yeah he's a i mean you know man he's a i
think he's probably
him and sean price
i think black thought gets a lot more
flowers than both of them but him and
sean price might be the two most slept
on mcs ever yeah
now fonte's hard and he can sing his
[ __ ] [ __ ] fonte is hard and funny
as [ __ ] and he's hilarious yeah funny
dude i think he's writing for like like
tv shows or something i'm not sure yeah
i wouldn't doubt it yeah i wouldn't
doubt it what is something that cause
they obviously got a tough shake um
you know
with some
with some shitty record deal [ __ ] you
know what i'm saying like what are some
of the things that like
who is kind of instilled in you to like
you know apply to your own career that
he had to go through first for you
literally um when
me and foo first started out he let me
know like look bruh this [ __ ] don't
happen overnight like he he [ __ ]
instilled that empty
into me like this [ __ ] don't happen
overnight like i know you see all the
[ __ ] that's going on and you see what's
happening but
it's it's a it's gonna take work so
you're gonna have to put in the work to
get this [ __ ] and also how to manage my
money better too
yeah that was like one of the the two
things that he um
instilled in me in the beginning like
it's important man yeah like watch your
money and at the same time
you got to put in the work if you want
to really really get somewhere because
you know what i love about pooh is he
was so transparent about like yo there
was a point in time where i was driving
uber like you know you know and and that
[ __ ] is i think that's dope because it
it lets rappers know like man this [ __ ]
ain't always sweet unless fans know that
because most rappers
have been in those vulnerable positions
but the perception is that they're never
in those vulnerable positions and that
they're always doing better than
everyone else but like what were some of
the money advice things that pooh had
kind of told you to like look out for
um basically like
just not aimlessly spending money on
dumb [ __ ] like you know and
when uh
when you get business situations like
just
spending money on you know the things
that you need to spend the money on and
not going out here and just
buying dumb [ __ ] like chains and [ __ ]
like a car that yeah it's a depreciating
asset
or cribs with extra rooms that you ain't
got no furniture in
that happens
i've been to so many houses just like
yeah we haven't decided we're gonna do
this room yet it's just there there's
boxes [ __ ] ain't doing [ __ ] with that
wrong
at all yo uh how did um you know the uh
dreamville situation uh initially kind
of take place like what i love about
cole is everyone he's ever signed
it's always artistic integrity first
if you think about re linux and like how
he's built her up like how
like you said nothing happens overnight
right boss a perfect example right you
know boss has got a record on the radio
right now and he's built up that fan
base over the last seven or eight years
so what you know obviously you being so
incredible as an artist like how did
that uh translate to getting on cole's
radar
um to be real with you people ask me
that a lot and i have no [ __ ] idea
like i was working at walmart
and
um i got a call from my friend and he's
like yo
cole just hit me up and said he [ __ ]
with your music and i'm like bro that
makes no sense why the hell would cole
hit you up and tell you that he [ __ ]
with my music and this was the time
where you know on twitter you had to be
following somebody
yeah so i guess cole had found my music
and he
i wasn't following him so
he found the closest person that i was
talking to like the most recent person i
was talking to and that was my friend so
he did my friend was following him
because he was a cold fan so
uh so he just hit your random homie yeah
he hit my homie he was like yo tell your
boy i [ __ ] with this music tell them
holla at me so my boy hitting me you
know like yo i'm sitting like bro you're
full of [ __ ] bro cause it's just your
normal homie
why would cole hit you up about my music
and
he just kept hitting me about it so i'm
like let me when i when i went on my
lunch break i'm like see what the [ __ ]
you talking about so as soon as i add
cold cold hit me it's like yo we have to
feel more this weekend pull up and i'm
gonna let you know how i found your
music and that's how it started what
year was this this was 20
either 2012 or 2013.
damn so this was this was almost 10
years ago yeah we're knocking i want to
say it was 2012. so that was he had nine
years ago yeah wow
[Music]
that's crazy yeah for cia i was like
damn like that's nuts so when people
like yo how did how did this happen i'm
like bro i can't tell you i don't know i
don't know how is that friend um
still your friend yeah no i still my boy
amazing yeah that's the best yeah that's
my brother
and so did you sign with him right away
no nah i literally signed
that was like i said that was 2012 2013
and i didn't get signed until like 2016.
so it took a minute
dude that's a crazy story let's talk
about working at walmart in north
carolina and what kind of crazy [ __ ] you
saw trash was this i almost had to scrap
a couple of people was this a 24 hour
walmart yeah it was 24 hours this is not
the one is this the walmart the baby
killed someone at no no okay not the
same it wasn't around that one okay i
don't know you gotta ask that was
actually pretty nice though that walmart
yeah that walmart despite everything
that happened or whatever despite that
that's the one
despite the homicide yeah that's the one
that's the one i go to like that's
literally the one
he's like yo for real [ __ ] like that's
the walmart you could go to and not see
38 juggalos at 2 a.m
but this shit's actually pretty nice
nice area that's your walmart the one
that's that's small that's the walmart
so the walmart you worked at was [ __ ]
up yeah yeah it's not even 24 hours no
more you know what i like to like when
when because i don't think walmarts are
24 hours at all now but when they were
fired you used to be able to go to
walmart at 3 a.m [ __ ] up after the
club and just people watch fire
like yo i want to see who's shopping at
walmart at 3 15 on a monday morning
and you'll go in there and it'll be like
a [ __ ] just
490 pound lady and a [ __ ] scooter
with a [ __ ] dog yeah
[ __ ] out her hand eating out of her
hand she's got [ __ ] tostitos pizza
rolls in her [ __ ] cart
she's got [ __ ] cow mine lotion for
her knees you know what i'm saying
it's [ __ ] up what's the craziest [ __ ]
you saw at walmart um a dude came
through dressed like a walmart employee
fire and left with like five to easy
fire
that's amazing that's like flies he was
like damn why you never think of that
bro he literally had on a blue shirt
khakis went to the back and was hauling
him out like you know as if he was
helping somebody take the tv this is why
you were working like during your shift
yeah
no one stopped them nobody stopped them
because they thought he was helping
somebody with the tv this is amazing
yeah
so i'm like yo
i gotta i gotta think of that next time
do you still have your walmart vest like
in the closet i'll have my uh the vest
but i still got the badge oh yeah we
never maybe we run that play man yeah
you know what this rap [ __ ] don't work
out we'll we'll go to walmart we'll
steal tvs
and [ __ ] and and pizza and pizza pizza
rolls yeah pizza rolls you know what i'm
saying
do you say you almost had to get into
fights
yeah i almost had to i had to get in
like a lot of fights to be honest
almost
about like what happened because for me
it's like bro i mean you know a job is a
job but i don't need this job that much
for you to be in here disrespecting me
and [ __ ]
yeah you know what i'm saying like
i don't talk to people i appreciate that
because you know what i hate is when you
go to walmart or or anywhere that's like
like a job that's like obviously you
know and people take the job so
seriously i hate [ __ ] like that when i
worked at target my uh oh you worked at
target too so you moved up yeah well you
think i did but
i actually moved down because i was
doing like the stocking and [ __ ] because
when i was at walmart i was cashing oh
you was on yeah you know what i'm saying
i was i was that [ __ ] well at least i
thought i was but um
but i went to target and i was like
stalking so i'm putting like noodles on
the shelf and [ __ ] ketchup
did you notice uh
aesthetically the human beings that went
to each place like improvingly different
yeah
shoppers at walmart and target shoppers
two completely different choppers which
ones are more attractive target okay
okay i just want to make sure that we're
right on with the stereotypes here yeah
it's true though it's true right it's
very true it's true yeah it's very true
you get a more higher quality at target
yeah
yo in north carolina
the walmart had to be like redneck
central right it was yeah it was a
little mix a little bling
confederate flags nascar
yeah it was definitely like up there
where lots of cargo shorts yeah
damn yeah that's walmart's a wild place
man it is though it is bro like
especially like when it was 24 hours so
after 12
because you got to shut down and like
kind of
um
they come by and like collect the money
or whatever and then they like switch
over another shift so after 12 [ __ ] gets
wild oh i'm already known i had a 24
hour walk right by my crib growing up we
used to just go there and [ __ ] with
people yeah man
did you have a mcdonald's in your
walmart
no we had a subway
[ __ ] i bet she was eating subway though
they got to the point where they was
like trying [ __ ] they was making pieces
yeah yeah they're still trying [ __ ] like
who wants a [ __ ] subway breakfast
ball what the [ __ ] are we doing here who
wakes up in the morning and says i'm
going to go to subway i'm not eating
breakfast
hell i don't even want to eat subs that
subway
subways like old faithful man
some of them 24 hour subways in l.a
you'd be like i got two options i got a
subway or i got mcdonald's i'm gonna go
get this sub hey what up man we got to
interrupt the interview real quick to
tell you about our family at odd socks
now when i be riding for odd socks so
hard man it's because i really love the
product they got the most comfortable
socks in the [ __ ] world i got a pair
of odd socks basics on right now go get
those they got the socks wwe joints you
know i'm saying shout out to the
undertaker pepsi [ __ ] really
whatever you need some weed socks
nickelodeon but really they got the
draws now ladies and gentlemen
i'm holding a pair of tapatio underwear
right now
you want some pop-tarts on your dick
pop-tart draws and these [ __ ]
are so comfortable
like
man so listen you gotta go to
oddssoxofficial.com
and use the uh promo code the discount
code bootleg kev
at oddssocksofficial.com you'll save 20
off underwear the most comfortable socks
in the world crazy licenses not only
they got the wwe they got the scarface
they got the street fighter they got the
nickelodeon they got it all so make sure
you hit that website oddsoxofficial.com
save 20 off with the promo code bootleg
kev all right go do that shout out to
odd socks let's get back to the
interview damn that's crazy so
you so you ended up when you were when
you signed in 2016 had you already left
like uh
retail and you know because i'm assuming
you met with coal in 2012
kept that relationship alive you're
probably dropping music were you
dropping music and working at the same
time or like yeah
and then um
i ended up getting fired from walmart
and i started uh working at the airport
oh that's rough too yeah yeah it is it
was but when i started working at the
airport
and my bread was looking a little
different
like in the in between
2012 and 2016
at a point i was working at the airport
for a minute
and
i had a daughter and i was like man [ __ ]
this rap [ __ ] like the money looking
good
this is like a career for me because i
was fueling planes
like yo i'm i'm no benefits yeah hell
yeah all kind of benefits i'm like man
[ __ ] this rap [ __ ] like what i need to
rap for and i got a child on the way i
said pop in the airport too
charlotte airport i mean it's cool i
mean i feel like i have i've had like
seven layovers there you know what's
crazy though like the one thing i loved
about working at the airport is
each day is never the same type [ __ ] you
know you work a regular job like i'm
doing the same [ __ ] every day like every
day was completely different you don't
know what the hell you was gonna get out
there
yeah i feel like a lot of layovers
happen in charlotte yeah like if you go
from the west coast to the east coast
sometimes you gotta what's that biscuit
place that's in the airport the um
it's like chicken and biscuits
it's in charlotte hmm [ __ ] is it called
you have to know this you've been on the
road so much
biscuit
no they have like
breakfast like chicken breakfast biscuit
sandwiches it's like a chain is it
starts with a bee bojangles bojangles oh
yeah hell yeah yeah that's the only time
i've only had it in in the charlotte
airport
so you never had it like at the actual
chain oh man yeah you gotta you gotta do
yourself a better
service next time you gotta how big of a
deal was it for you cole and baby to be
on a record together at that time it was
fine especially for
for north carolina right because but i
felt for me like at the time
um
i felt like it was fire but at the same
time like man i'm in the middle don't
nobody know the [ __ ] i am but that's why
it was dope for you yeah no it was
though it was they're like yo this guy
who's this [ __ ] guy lou so i'm like
man i don't know how i don't know how
people are gonna react to this because
i'm like you know you got cold you got
the baby and then you just got this guy
in the middle but the responses was fire
like i loved it
and then you got you got a grammy
nomination from that which is a [ __ ]
big deal yeah
were you there when uh
chris bosh was pulling up with beats yes
bro that was trippy as hell like to come
around the corner and you see chris bosh
in the corner
making beats and [ __ ] and they were
fired right better than chris webber's
beats have ever been yo this was fine
chris bosh is [ __ ]
hey man
one of the biggest what-ifs well he's
probably like top 10 what if in nba
history there's some bigger what-ifs but
so yeah so you did you end up getting on
any of his beats no i didn't get on the
beats but the ones i heard was fire as
hell were you there when the bucks all
came yeah i was there too wow yeah
that was another moment where i was like
yo this is random as hell can you honest
just hanging out yeah just chilling with
t-shirts and
bucks hats
cookie mugs and stuff they just brought
you guys a bunch of products [ __ ] and
food they brought food too the bucks
catered a dreamville session that whole
that whole day wow were you able to
connect with anybody uh on the bucks at
all at that time no i know cause i was
mad like ducked off
yeah plus you're probably a hornets fan
right
yeah i guess i mean it's gotta be nice
to be a hornets fan now that you guys
look like you have a future well i'll be
honest i don't really watch basketball
like that really yeah yeah that's fair
not really
you watch any sports i watch football i
mean you know you gotta say i'm darnold
yeah leading the league and touchdown
brushes right now i like sam darnold
he's killing it yeah now he is he is i
mean we lost our last two games but my
producer just traded for him in fantasy
football right yeah nah he's fired yeah
solid
in north carolina man
you know there's so much culture there i
feel like see i i like you said ci
double a is always there we don't have
it no more no i was because we went to
like baltimore yeah it moved right
mm-hmm and that you know baltimore is
not gonna
yeah who knows we'll see it back
um
how is like the reception of the album
been in the small amount of time that
it's been out
honestly man it's been really
crazy i was uh surprised because i
honestly i'm like
i didn't know how this was gonna go i
was kind of nervous to put this out
because i never put an album out or i
never really did something like this
where i felt so exposed and i was like
mad um vulnerable vulnerable
you know so
it was giving me anxiety to put it out
because i'm like damn i just don't know
how it's going to be perceived because i
didn't go in here with no intentions to
make bangers or
a single or anything like i just went
over i just want to in the studio invent
it
you know so
i didn't know how they was going to
perceive it and so when it dropped and
saw i saw i didn't see the responses
until sort of the album dropped monday
right
this was nuts album dropped monday
i didn't see the responses until
thursday because my phone had got [ __ ]
up oh wow right so i couldn't swipe up
oh wow see the screen or anything
so
um i finally go to apple
and i get it fixed and um
and dude it's like yo uh you loot
i was like yeah he's like yo your
album's fire it's like yo i appreciate
it i'm glad you [ __ ] with it because i
can't see anything yeah he's like oh bet
like let's get you squared away and they
did
and that's when i saw like all the
responses and everybody
really [ __ ] with the album i thought
that [ __ ] was fine
i think when you go in and you purposely
try to make a single or a banger it
never works right
i didn't even i didn't even i wasn't
even thinking like that though i just
literally went to the studio and was
just venting and [ __ ] yeah that's the
[ __ ] that cuts through man that's what
people want to hear at the end of the
day
like you said earlier like
when you make a body of work you want
people to listen to the whole body of
work you don't want to be an artist like
i always tell everybody there's
longevity in being an artist who puts
out bodies of work and not depends on
hit records you know what i'm saying not
for that because you could do the hard
like like get that hard ticket money get
the [ __ ] get that following who will
buy all your merch or support whatever
you do like and the way you're gonna do
that is just by being true to yourself
bro because that's that's what people
relate to you know for sure you know
what i'm saying what was like um for you
like uh
you got some dope features obviously
causes on the album you got some you
know obviously aries on the album but
what was like
a feature that
maybe was like a little
down to the wire on this project
or were they all pretty much
you know um
i say the most down to the wire feature
was bj but it was like
it was so fire though
because like
i'm hitting him like yo i really
appreciate you doing this like so
because i know it's so last minute but
like y'all really appreciate you doing
this and he's like nah bruh i appreciate
you even reaching out to me to do it so
slept on yeah nah for sure somehow he
still slept for sure man and and but how
that [ __ ] worked out
was crazy but it was definitely down to
the wire like it was like super last
minute are you gonna um
are you gonna like
follow you know i think with when when
we think of cole i think cole like
always makes us kind of wait right
for an album
boss is the same way
how is like now that you're you finally
got this project off your chest do you
plan on like getting back in soon and
like keeping up cause you know now y'all
get what you're saying you know i i do
plan on digging a baby the baby dropped
like three four [ __ ] seven albums in
two years it was a lot bro it was just a
lot going on i'm not doing all that no
i'm saying but jesus christ yeah now um
because for me when it comes to projects
and like bodies of work i really like to
take my time of course uh live life a
little right but i don't be meaning to
take like years
i really like to take my time but i feel
like what people don't realize is like
[ __ ] we go through [ __ ] too like life
happens yeah so
even though we don't intentionally or at
least i know i don't intentionally mean
to be
you know dropping albums at four-year
span or whatever just [ __ ] i'll be going
through [ __ ] hey and that [ __ ] that you
go through gives you more more content
to write about i don't be mad about the
[ __ ] that i go through because i'm like
any situation whether good or bad
especially bad situation i'm like yo
this shit's [ __ ] up but at the same
time it's gonna make for a good song
you know so i can't really be too mad
about the situation i can't be really
too down on my luck because i know it's
gonna
it's gonna come out to be a great song
somewhere along the lines have you guys
uh kicked around the idea of doing uh
another revenge of the dreamers
oh uh i don't know
i don't know i don't know i know that
there's like a lot of records that just
didn't make by the way shout out to ebay
those hella records they didn't mean why
no you know we talked about sequencing
yeah eve did such a great job
of putting together
a front-to-back just press play and
that's so much harder to do with a
compilation and i'm sure with like the
batch of records that he had to choose
from
and then when you looked at the track
list you're like what the [ __ ] is like
i want to know what's what's got that
sounding like on some dream bill [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying but it was it
was
hard no what that's fire it's [ __ ]
hard yeah yeah no he's a great guy too
at that time i didn't even know he
rapped i'm just so used to seeing him
he's like he's like a meme yeah and like
in like doing funny [ __ ] but when he was
in there spitting i was like yo he's
fired who are um like if you had to
like uh you know top three or four
artists all time
um odb
uh ceelo
and
biggie the only reason why i say biggie
is because like his flow is just
butter we just had a conversation about
this together like butter it's crazy i
think the only artist i was saying this
yesterday the only artist who has ever
gotten close to me feeling like god that
was so buttery is ross like when ross
raps on some [ __ ] you think so it just
slides off the beat i don't listen to
ross like that oh you should man
teflon dawn is a [ __ ] classic no no
not notice it's just it's too slow for
me i get it nah it's crazy so you said
odb ceelo you know what's crazy is the
first time i ever heard cee-lo
was
on
i want to say it was on equipment when i
was a kid
but man his voice
when he came in
it was like who the [ __ ] is this but
this is when he was rapping this before
i even like there was a song called they
don't dance no more by goody mob yeah
nah and the way he came in on the end of
that record it was like
who the [ __ ] is this bro goody mom is
like one of my favorite rap groups of
all time so it's like when i heard ceelo
i'm like yo this dude is
[ __ ] nuts
and then when they did uh the nars
barkley [ __ ] of course
this guy's insane nah he's a beast man
and oh i mean odb is obviously i'm a
huge wu tank fan so i feel like od we
don't talk about what he being enough
when talking about him though ghost face
gets love meth gets left yeah
odb man
he brought a lot of character to those
albums
and put out
you know
one amazing album and and n word please
was solid you know
what was like for what what gravitated
to towards odp man
just his style
like he just he was very like
raw
he didn't feel to himself you know what
i'm saying it was no filter with him
like when he uh went to the [ __ ] put out
in the in the limo with the with the
food stamps
like what like man
that's the type of [ __ ] i'm on like yeah
you know just raw and like true like he
was too can you imagine if social media
was the way it was when odb was alive
how [ __ ] lit he'd be on bro
his instagram be [ __ ] insane but i
love that though i love that about him
and i love that about artists i love
when the artists can just be like
themselves and like be like super true
and super like unfiltered so would you
take goody mob over outcast
yes oh i would but andre is in my top
five like greatest rappers of all time
and big boy people sleep on big boy too
like big boys don't give him his credit
i agree but um well yeah i would say
goody my bubba over outcast okay i would
would you okay
well
obviously what what is soul food's your
favorite goody mom album um
yeah i had a conversation about that a
couple days ago but yeah is it still
standing or soul food i mean to me those
are probably the two you'd pick from
right yeah yeah yeah but soul food yeah
i think soul food is my so
how about let me ask you like this would
you take
soul food over any outcast album
no
because
equipment is kind of like one of my one
of my favorite that's the one favorite
outcast
you know it's crazy when you talk to
outcast fans there's equipment eye
people and then there's at aliens people
by the way i love both albums right but
there's people who swear by either one
of those is their best album and i'm
like i'm an equipment i got it i'm on
the equipment i train man then you get
the cds and it's got the women on them
oh yeah
every [ __ ] outcast i had a naked
[ __ ] on it it was amazing as a kid it
was amazing and you know what was crazy
is when you had a homie who had to get
the album from walmart the [ __ ] cds
had [ __ ] the titties blurred out yeah
yeah yeah
version
had i was like oh this is the clean
version now get that [ __ ] away from me
the titties are covered up
wow
you appreciated [ __ ] like that oh my god
because it didn't really go with like it
didn't go to anything it was just naked
women on the
on the cd cover there's a guy who makes
rugs i forget his name he makes like
custom like cd rugs yeah i think i know
you're talking about i've seen him and
he did uh um
i want to say he did the equipment cd
or no he did he did um he did the love
below but i was like man i wish somebody
would do at aliens with the like cartoon
naked chick
yeah no that's crazy yeah okay so i just
want to make sure you know equipment
night to me is like top five album ever
so
soul food's great but you know i gotta
go with the quim and i over
over soul food for sure i just feel like
they were like with soulful or just
goody mom in general like they had a
daytime especially how people are now
with like hey you get eating good you
know what i'm saying being woke or
whatever it's just like bro these [ __ ]
was tapped in think about gip and uh
and
and andre just fashion wise like
they were kind of like the og young thug
like you know when young thug was doing
his [ __ ] i'm like man this is just some
[ __ ] nonsense in a sense i'm just like
breaking where people cause you know
everyone used to think andre was gay i
mean he said it on equipment is he on
drugs is he gay oh true what i'm saying
yeah i just like the fact that he was
just but he was different he was himself
right but again i like artists think
about that in the 90s exactly that [ __ ]
was looked way crazier then because it
was like who the [ __ ] is this guy
wearing wigs and [ __ ]
but nah nah man i hope i hope
andre comes out of retirement we need
one more outcast though only thing is
i'm afraid if they do one more album i'm
afraid it would suck i'm not saying it
would suck but that'd be my only fear
it's like what if it's not good yeah
but then
being an artist is like
i kind of feel andre though
like [ __ ] i kinda did what i needed to
do
i ain't really gotta i'm one album of
the year yeah i'm gonna go to [ __ ]
stuff diamond i'm gonna play my
instrument i'm chilling
he's not even really acting anymore
i haven't seen him in the movie for
forever i feel like he's chilling like
he probably had at a point in his life
where he like bro i'm good where i'm at
i'm fine
i'm
out here with my kids
most steps most steps like that too who
could you know one of the greatest
artists want to reach out to me and do
whatever and link up and do a song like
i'm totally down to do it just to get
that blessing but other than that i'm at
the crib did you hear the uh kanye uh
song that was had andre on it that
leaked that was yeah yeah i did hear it
how did that not end up on donna man
i ain't chipping for that he's tripping
i mean i ain't be tripping but he'd be
tripping but i'm like bro this is one of
the best andre versus i've heard in a
long [ __ ] time
i also like how on 30 hours he just had
him saying in 30 hours yeah yeah yeah
that's just fire 30 hours to do that the
life of pablo doesn't get enough love
that album is [ __ ] crazy
that actually was a good album i loved
that album
i was not a fan of jesus as king don is
solid but jesus is king i don't know i
mean i'm not a big religious guy so i
don't know but hey look so the album is
out um
i know you uh you know is this your
first official album on dreamweaver yeah
this is my first official studio i know
a lot of people think that west 1996
part two was my official album but that
was just my mixtape because you know
it's [ __ ] you know people call it price
i was gonna say shit's dicey these days
because everything ends up on dsp so is
it an album is it a mixed day yeah no
it was a project right but uh so this is
the album yeah this is the album
yeah when um
did did cole have any input on the album
when he heard it
he loved it
he told me he played you know but uh as
far as like how everything went it was
just me and
pooh and fonte
bro that's so fire that you just got
[ __ ] little brother in your corner
man yeah we have to make
the little brother jake also eve like uh
eve is again like when i used to have
like music and stuff i'll definitely
play my music for eve because eve will
let me know if some [ __ ] was fired like
because i recorded most of the album
here in la okay and then i finished it
up when i went back to the crib so when
i was here and e was available i would
play some [ __ ] just to see if he was
rocking with it and if he was rocking
with it i'm like this cool
and if not because you know i trust
eve's ear of music because like he's got
a great ear man inspired with it but um
but yeah other than that like when i got
back to the crib and that's when the
work really went in with like the
sequencing and
uh
the musicians well we have musicians
here in l.a too but just getting
everybody and getting pieces piecing it
together you have to bring little
brother and j cole together
on a record
this hap this has to be your mission for
north carolina's history
how this has not happened yet
is is beyond me that would be nice drake
is on a song with fonte
true
you know why i [ __ ] with drake off the
rip because he had an interview like in
like oh nine and he said fonte was like
one of his biggest influences i was like
oh this guy's like a
oh he likes real rap
j cole needs a song with pooh and fonte
bro that's true for the culture that's
true and you are the guy who's gonna
make it happen i'm the i'm the liaison
you have to make it happen on the next
album
you
little brother j cole
yeah that [ __ ] is gonna be nice
i mean it's historical
i'm just glad we put a lot of respect on
little brother's name in this interview
because one of the greatest rat groups
of all time for sure
1 000 for sure
so hey man go get the album it's out
right now um hopefully we get a revenge
of the dreamers for you know i'm sure
it'll probably be in the next couple of
years
i would love that too the last one did
so well yeah it was fine it's crazy the
level up too because the first two were
kind of like under the radar like just
kind of thrown out there for the further
like the the fans but that third one was
like no we're [ __ ] we're going
augusta with this yeah
now the third one was was definitely one
where it's just like yo that was a time
those sessions i mean
i'm assuming that there'll be a
documentary one day it has to be
just with those sessions i just want to
see chris bosh making beats on a laptop
two is impactful for me too cause
uh still summon was
on two
[Music]
that's why people heard it first
and i never forget when that [ __ ] came
out
i went to the closest best buy bought
like four cds
i had two for myself i had one where i
wasn't going to open one i opened i
remember the city all day listening to
that [ __ ] wow yeah
that [ __ ] was that the first time you
were able to buy a cd that you like at
best buy with you on it with me on it
yeah that's a big deal yeah i bought
like well at the time for me it was mad
cds because i was broke but yeah you
know buying four cds there used to be a
thing like where like you'd go support
an artist like uh you know and they
i think there was a actually j cole
there was a time where drake and j cole
went to best buy
in new york do you remember that yeah i
remember that and drake bought all the
coal albums off the shelf yeah and it
was like it was like a thing but now
obviously shout out to best buy man yeah
because they don't even have a cd uh i
don't know what's going on i don't know
what's going on over there yeah i just
recently went the best box because i had
to get a usb for some [ __ ] but
yeah they don't even have they don't
even have a cd they don't have any cds
i'm just tripping on how they still got
blu-rays yeah no that's just nice too
who the [ __ ] is still buying blu-rays
juggalos
juggalos
for sure yeah and that's how we end
things with we started with juggalos
we're ending with juggalos
the homie loot how many times you get
called lut
man
let i get caught have you ever been
called luther
a nice lovely like like lady like
spanish lady from honolulu
no no
ain't been hit with the lieutenant
though i definitely get that [ __ ]
it's loot ladies and gentlemen yeah
thank you for coming through man i
appreciate you better yes sir